Gençler merhaba. Hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
9. sınıf konuları. Kaldığımız yerden
devam ediyoruz. Dediğim gibi artık son
konuların içerisindeyiz.
Bugünkü derslerimizde
hücre organellerinden ve hücresel
yapılardan prokaryot ve ökaryot hücre
ayrımından bahsedeceğiz. O zaman ne
diyoruz? Hadi gelin birlikte öğrenelim.
Aslında bir sınıflandırma bilgisine
sahibiz. Prokaryot ve ökaryot hücreleri
işledik. Nasıl işledik hocam?
Bakteriler, arkeler, bunlardan
bahsetmiştik. Hatırlıyor musunuz?
Protista, bitki, mantar ve hayvan.
Bakteri ve arkeler neydi? Prokaryottu.
Zarlı, organel ve çekirdek yapıları
bulunmayan canlılardı. Lütfen prokaryot
tek hücrelidir, ökaryotlar çok
hücrelidir şeklinde bir tanım yapmayın.
Tamam. Evet. Prokaryotlarda bunu
tutturursunuz. Bakteriler ve arkeler tek
hücrelidir. Ama ökaryotlar içerisinde
tek hücreli canlılar da var ki
koskocaman protista aleminden bahsettik
ve hatta mantarlar içerisinde de maya
mantarları tek hücrelidir dedik. Tamam
bitki ve hayvanların tek hücreli formu
yok ama lütfen dikkatli olalım tanımları
yaparken. Prokaryot zarlı organel ve
çekirdek içermeyen demek. Çok hücreli
canlılar genellikle doku organ
sistemleşmeye giderler.
Ancak özelleşmiş bir yapı varsa, bir
hücre varsa tek başına hayatta kalma
becerisini yitirmiştir. Bu ne demek?
Görev paylaşımı. Hocam şimdi kalp
hücresi tek başına hayatta kalamaz.
Neden? Birinin ona oksijen getirmesi
lazım. Birinin ona besin taşınması
lazım. Birinin onu uyarması lazım gibi
düşünülebilir. Ama tek başına bir hücre
hayatta kalabilir. Mesela bakteri zaten
tek bu adam. Peki, prokaryot hücrelerde
arkadaşlar zarlı organel ve çekirdek yok
deriz ama bir çekirdek alanı ya da
nükleer bölge şeklinde bir ifade var. Bu
ne demek biliyor musunuz? Bu çekirdek
var demek değil. Bu halkasal DNA'nın
bulunduğu konumu ifade eder bize. Bazı
birçok bazı kelimelerine dikkat edin.
Bir işaret koymuşum. Siz bir bakteriye
baktığınız zaman hücre zarını,
sitoplazmasını, halkasal DNA'sını,
ribozomunu, RNA'sını görürsünüz. Ancak
bazı bakterilerde kamçı, bazılarında
kapsül, bazılarında klorofil,
birçoğunda hücre duvarı şeklinde
ifadelere dikkat edin. Bunlar dünyadaki
bütün bakterilerde bulunan yapılar değil
arkadaşlar. bazı ve birçok ifadesine o
yüzden dikkat edin. Yine piluslar
tutunma ya da konjügasyon köprüsü
kurmayı sağlıyordu. Kamçı yer değiştirme
hareketi zaten. Prokaryotlarda tüm
yaşamsal olaylar öyleyse hücre zarı ve
sitoplazma gibi yapılarda olacak. Ama
bunların spesifik özelleşmiş organelleri
var mı? Yok hocam. Yani işte golgidir,
endoplazmik etikulundur, lizozomdur.
Bunlar bakteri ve arkelerde olmayacak.
Ökaryot hücreler protista, bitki, mantar
ve hayvanların arkadaşlar sahip olduğu
hücrelerdi. Bunlar da bir çekirdek
olacak. Yönetici molekülü içeren yani
DNA'yı içeren. Bir de özelleşmiş yapılar
olacak. Her birinin kendine özgü
görevleri olacak. Hücrelerin yapısal
bileşenlerine baktığınızda
temel anlamda aslında hücre zarını ve
protoplazmayı görüyorsunuz. Ökaryot
ifadesini vurgulayacağım burada.
Protoplazma çekirdek ve sitoplazmadan
meydana geliyor. Sitoplazmada sitosol
dediğimiz sıvı kısım ve organellerin
kendisinden meydana geliyor. Hücre zarı
bugünün konusu değil. Hücre zarı ve
madde alışverişlerini spesifik olarak
öğretirken hücre zarından çok fazla
bahsedeceğim. İşte akıcı mozegar modeli
diyeceğim. Hücrenin çevresiyle
iletişimi, maddelerin atılması ya da
alınması, hücrelerin birbiriyle
haberleşmesi vesaire gibi görevlere
sahiptir diyeceğim ama dediğim gibi bunu
sonraki bölümde anlatacağım. Sitoplazma,
plazma zarı ile çekirdek arasında kalan
sıvı kısım. Prokaryotlarda hücre zarının
çevrelediği alanın tümü zaten
sitoplazma. Neden? Çünkü çekirdek gibi
bir yapı yok. Sitoplazmadın organel
çeşitliliği canlılar arasında farklılık
gösterir arkadaşlar. Buna dikkat
edeceksiniz. Hani bu ne demek? Ben
diyeceğim ki mesela bir X canlısında şu
organel vardır ama Y canlısında yoktur.
ÖSYM'nin de çok sevdiği soru tiplerinden
bir tanesi. Sitoplazma içerisinde
iskelet proteinler yani hücre iskeletini
sağlayan işte organellerin hareketi,
sabitlenmesi,
zarın fonksiyonlarından bazılarının
yerine getirilmesi, hücreler arası
bağlantıların kurulması gibi görevlere
sahip olan hücre iskeleti bulunacak.
Hücrenin sitoplazması ve zara yakın
konumunda. Şöyle hızlı bir soru çözelim.
Burada ökaryotik hücrelerle ilgili
açıklamalardan hangisi yanlıştır?
Sitoplazma sıvı kısım ile organellerden
oluşur. Doğru bir ifade. Metabolik
olayların tümü sitoplazmada
gerçekleşmiyor. Ökaryotlarda organeller
ve hücresel yapılar var. Çekirdek belli
bir işlevi yapmak üzere özelleşmiş
organellerden biridir. Bitki ve hayvan
hücrelerinde farklı işlevler için
özelleşmiş organeller bulunabilir.
Sitoplazma hücre zarı ile çekirdek
arasında kalan bölümdür. Ribozom bir
organel midir? Değildir arkadaşlar.
ribozom, sentrozom, hücre iskelet
elemanları. Bunlar organel değildir.
Çünkü organelin bir tanımı var aslında.
Zarlı yapı ama bunlarda bir zar yok.
Protein sentezini gerçekleştiren
ribozomdur. Zarla çevrili olmadığı için
organel olarak nitelendirilmesi doğru
değildir. Tüm canlılarda ortak olarak
bulunan bir yapıdır ribozom. Çünkü her
canlı bir şekilde protein sentezi
yapıyor. En kötü ihtimal hücre zarına
protein koyuyor. Enzim sentezliyor.
Peptit bağlarının oluşumunu katalizleyen
ribozomal RNA. Bakın bir enzim var ve bu
enzim protein yapılı değil RNA yapılı.
Ribozomun yapısı ribozomal RNA ve
proteinden meydana gelir ve ribozomal
RNA enzim gibi davranıp peptit bağını
katalizler. Aşağıda nükleoprotein diye
bir kelime yazmışım ve soru işareti
koymuşum. Bir yapının içerisinde nükleik
asit ve protein varsa biz buna ne
diyormuşuz? Nükleoprotein diyormuşuz.
Ribozomal RNA ökarik hücrelerde
çekirdekçikte DNA'dan sentezlenir.
Protein de çekirdeğin dışında
sentezlenip çekirdeğin içerisine alınır.
Çekirdekçikte bu yapılar birleştirilerek
ribozom üretilir. İşte bu da bir ÖSYM
sorusudur. Ribozomu kim üretir?
Çekirdekçik. Ribosom nerelerde bulunur?
Sitoplazmada serbest. Endoplazmik
retikulumun üzerinde mitokondri ve
kloroplastın içinde bulunur. Arkadaşlar
prokaryot ribozomuyla ökaryot ribozomu
farklıdır. Hatta mitokondri ve
kloroplast içindeki ribozomlarla
diğer ribozomlar da farklılık
gösterebilir. Bunun evrimsel bir nedeni
var ama müfredatımızda olmadığı için
anlatmıyorum. Ökaryotik ribozomlar
prokaryotik ribozomlardan büyüktür.
Ribozomlarla ilgili hangisi söylenemez
demişiz. Prokaryot hücre yapısına sahip
ilkel bir hücreli de bulunmaz. Yanlış.
Ribozom neydi? evrenseldi. Büyük ve
küçük alt birimden oluşur. Yapısında
protein ve RRNA bulunur. Nükleoprotein
sitoplazmada serbest halde ya da bazı
organellerin zarına tutunmuş durumda
bulunabilir. Kloroplast ve mitokondri
gibi organellerin kendine özgü
ribozomları vardır. Sentrozomu da bir
hücresel yapı olarak değerlendireceğiz.
Yine zarı yok. Organel olarak ifade
etmek doğru olmaz. Hücre bölünmesinde
işlev yapanlar nedir? i iplikleri.
Bunlar da mikrotübülden oluşur. Şimdi
arkadaşlar sentrozom mikrotübülleri
organize eder. Tamam mı? Epli sentezler
ifadesi çok doğru bir ifade değil.
organize eder ifadesi doğrudur. Ve bu
mikrotübüllerin organizasyonundan
sorumlu
yer mikrotübül organizasyon merkezi
adını alır. İşte hayvanlarda
mikrotübülleri organize eden bölge
sentrozomdur. Hocam bitkilerde
mikrotübülleri organize eden bölge var
mı? Var ama sentriol sentrozom gibi bir
yapı yoktur arkadaşlar. Anlaştık mı? Bu
çok spesifik bir ÖSYM sorusudur. Hangisi
bitkilerde bulunmaz? Bakın bitki
hücrelerinde sentriol yok. Spermleri
kamçılı olan kara yosunları ve eğrelti
otları gibi bitkilerde sentriol benzeri
yapılara rastlanır. Sentriolün kendisine
değil benzeri yapılara rastlanır. Ve bu
bir çift sentriol sentrozomu meydana
getiriyor. Ve bu sentrioller arkadaşlar
mikrotübüllerin
şu şekilde üçlü üçlü dizilmesiyle
oluşuyor ve bundan 9 tane var. Yani 9un
üçlü dizilmeleriyle 27 mikrotübülden
oluşan yapılardır. Bir çift sentriol
sentrozom. Sentrozomlar mikrotübül
organize edici bölgeler içeriyorlar ve
dolayısıyla arkadaşlar bölünmede de
görev almış oluyorlar. Bölünmeden önce
sayısını iki katına çıkartır. Bu videoda
çekirdekten de bahsedip bitireceğim.
Hani 1 2 3 şeklinde gidecek videolar.
Çekirdek hücrenin yönetim merkezidir.
Neden? İçinde çünkü DNA var.
DNA özel proteinlerde sarılmış durumda.
Hemen şunu hatırlamanızı istiyorum.
DNA'nın yapısında protein yok
arkadaşlar. Bakın DNA nükleotit polimeri
değil mi? Siz çocuklarsınız. Bakın
nükleotit polimeri. Nükleotitte ne var?
Baz, şeker, fosfat. Bak amino asit yok,
protein yok. DNA eğer proteinle
sarılırsa bunun adı nedir? kromatindir.
Kromatinin yapısında protein var ve
hücre bölünürken kromatinler kısalıp
kalınlaşarak kromozomları meydana
getirir. Yani dinlenme anında kromozom
göremezsiniz. Kromozomları hücre
bölünmesi sırasında görürsünüz. Çekirdek
sayısı, çekirdeğin büyüklüğü hücreler
arasında farklılık gösterebilir. Mesela
iskelet kası hücrelerimiz çok
çekirdeklidir. Embironik hayatta iskelet
kası hücreleri kaynaşırlar arkadaşlar.
Dolayısıyla bir hücre birden fazla
hücrenin kaynaşmasıyla oluştuğu için çok
çekirdekli görülür. Bazı hücrelerde
farklı büyüklükte çekirdek olabilir.
Mesela paramesyumda bir tane küçük bir
tane büyük çekirdek bulunur. Bazı
özelleşmiş hücreler de farklılaşırken
çekirdeğini kaybeder. Mesela bizdeki
olgun aluvarlar çekirdek ve bazı
hücresel yapılarını kaybederek
olgunlaşırlar. Buna dikkat edeceğiz. Ha
tabii karşımıza bitkilerin kalburlu boru
hücreleri de çıkacak. O da zamanı
geldiğinde çok tatlı soruya dönüşecek.
Çekirdeğin temel yapısına baktığınız
zaman çekirdek zarfı, çekirdek plazması,
kromatin, çekirdekçik olmak üzere dört
bölümde incelendiğini görüyorsunuz.
Çekirdek zarfı çift katlı zardır
arkadaşlar. Bazen mitokondri
kloroplastla ortak özelliği nedir
tarzında sorular çıkabiliyor karşınıza.
Dış zarını endoplazmik retikulum yapar
ve üzerinde ne var? Ribozom var.
çekirdeğin zarının üzerinde ribozom
bulunabilir. Bölünme sırasında çekirdek
zarı parçalanır. Sonra tekrar arkadaşlar
oluşturulur.
Tıp fakültesinde çok tatlı bir mekanizma
öğreneceksiniz. Bu zar yapısının oluşumu
ve ayrılması sırasında. Hatta burada bir
problem, bir defekt, genetik bir kusur
varsa erken yaşlanma hastalığı çıkacak
karşınıza. Meraklısı araştırabilirim.
Hocam çekirdek zarındaki geçitler
büyüktür. Öyle ki mRNA gibi, tena gibi,
ribozom gibi yapılar çekirdeğin dışına
çıkabiliyor, değil mi? Ama bu şu anlama
gelmiyor. İsteyen istediği gibi girer,
çıkar anlamına gelmiyor. Küçük
moleküllerin birçoğunun geçişine mesela
izin vermeyebiliyor. Öyleyse çekirdek
zarı seçicidir. Çekirdek içerisinde bir
sıvı var. Bu sıvı sitoplazmaya göre
yoğun. Çok fazla protein içeriyor
burası. İçinde enzim, mineral, nükleotit
ve diğer maddeler bulunuyor. Kalıtım
molekülümüz DNA. Çekirdek içerisinde
özel proteinlere sarılı. Bu protein adı
ne? Histon proteini. Hocam DNA
proteinlerle sarılı halde neyi
oluşturuyordu? kromatin ipliğini
oluşturuyordu ve hücre bölünürken
kromatinler yoğunlaşıp daha belirgin
hale geliyordu. Kromatinler çekirdek
içinde kendine özgü bölgelerde dağınık
halde bulunuyor. Kromatinler bölünme
öncesinde arkadaşlar daha fazla sarmal
ve katlanmalar yaparak kısalıp
kalınlaşıyor. Böylece daha yoğun hale
geliyor. Şunlar çok kıymetli bilgiler.
Bir türe ait bireylerin hepsi ki
istisnalar elbette var. Aynı kromozom
sayısına sahiptir. Nasıl istisna var
hocam? Şimdi insan 46 kromozomlu
ama mesela arılara bakıyorsun dişisi 2n
kromozomlu erkeği n kromozomlu ama biz
yine de genelleme yapabiliriz. İşte bir
türün sağlıklı bireylerin kromozom
sayısının aynı olması beklenir gibi.
Kromozom sayısı bir canlının
gelişmişliği ile ilgili bilgi vermez.
Eğrel otu 500 küsür kromozom var. Senden
daha mı gelişmiş? Hayır hocam. Farklı
türden bireylerin kromozom sayısı aynı
olabilir. Bu onları aynı sınıfa
sokmuyordu. Zaten gelişmişlik hakkında
bilgi vermiyordu. İşte insan, kurtbağ
bitkisi, moli balığı 46 kromozomludur.
Genler kromozomlar üzerinde taşınır.
Bunu unutmayın lütfen. Ve bir kromozomun
üzerinde kaç tane gen olduğunu öyle bir
genelleme yaparak hesaplayamazsınız.
Bakterilerde kromozomlar halkasal,
ökaryotlarda arkadaşlar doğrusaldır,
lineerdir. Ve ökaryotlarda DNA histon
proteinleri ile çevrilidir. Bunu
unutmayın. Ama histon proteinleri ilk
nerede karşımıza çıkıyordu? Bazı
arkelerde. Tamam. Bütün arkelerde istom
proteini var demeyin sakın. Bazı
arkelerdi.
Kromozomlarla ilgili hangisi söylenemez?
Ökaryotlarda çekirdektedir. Sayısı
canlının gelişmişliği hakkında bilgi
vermez. taşıdığı gen sayısı değişkendir.
Farklı türün bireylerinde aynı sayıda
kromozom bulunabilir. Prokaryotlarda
arkadaşlar genellikle n kromozomlu
yapıdadır. Çekirdekçik bir ÖSYM
sorusuydu.
Ayrı bir organel ya da hücresel bir yapı
olarak görmeyeceğiz bunu. Çekirdek
özellikle RR RRNA sentezleyen bölümdür.
RRNA ile beraber proteinleri birleştirip
arkadaşlar neyi meydana getiriyordu?
Ribozomu meydana getiriyordu. Tamam mı?
ribozom alt birimlerini üreten
çekirdekçik
yapısıdır. Evet, endoplazmik etikuluma
girmiyorum. Burada bir mola verelim.
Sonrasında
bu yapılarla devam edeceğiz.
Yeah.